[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le monde a attendu ce qui semblait être une
éternité,
puis
nous avons attendu plus longtemps,
mais en février,
nous promettons que ce sera la
merde la plus horrible de tous les temps,
l'attente est terminée
[Musique]
bonjour je suis johnny knoxville bienvenue à
jackie
si tu es  va être stupide tu dois être
dur
s'ils nous font confiance pour aller aux toilettes
ils sont moins intelligents que je ne le pensais
dans le tiroir mais j'en sais assez
pour savoir
si tu vas être stupide tu dois être
dur tu fais encore exploser les gens  debout comme
si la vie n'était pas assez dure ce mec est un
mec dur à cuire
quel est le pire qui puisse arriver
[Musique]
tu as dit que ça ne ressemblerait à
rien
[Musique]
j'ai juste besoin que tu aimes m'asseoir avec mon
grand-père, assure-toi juste qu'il ne fume pas
un tas de scientifiques de la nasa en ce moment puis-
je obtenir  une boisson fraîche
[Musique]
lui feras-tu une vraie
étape café  Hanie je t'en ai fait un autre
ça doit être fini mec je pense qu'on a
tout fini on a fini de
mettre une fourchette dedans